welcome to this video playing addiction
from Australia yep let's go for the NIMS
Oh a good old names oh we have maybe the
Zurich my book line yeah this book here
it is a neverending story now we are at
the end of May and it's still allowed I
have submitted the book on in in
February more than three months ago but
the publisher is just I know they take a
long time somehow to get things sorted
out I mean it sorted out is the wrong
word I mean it there are some processes
that have to be done obviously to get
the book release but takes forever I
don't really know how because the way I
submitted it it was basically just ready
to be released and there was nothing
it's not much that needed to be done ok
so I I mixed a mixed systems here this
g-form check is an interesting way to
play that I have that I had featured in
my book so it's really an interesting
way to play for a white but I have
confused the move order here and why it
is probably having pretty decent chances
here I mean it's not terribly bad for me
but in comparison I probably should have
gotten a bit bit of a better position so
let's see EG form hmm
yeah my ideas that now I have 94 and
after Queen somewhere i have Bishop f5
was my idea no he's going there I
expected Quincy to something like that
hmm okay let's check the Queen that
that's really weird Queen to a true wow
so night be 30 he's taking this now
allowing night b3 and Bishop f5 looks
really strange so yeah he took he took
the he took the night so I can still go
them yeah i think i should actually
night on b3 smacking that looks really
good so let's try to put the night on v3
so ok Bishop f5 or Bishop e6 both
looking good that may be here not spend
too much time he has before but this is
not a transformation that various me
very much excellent would be of course
if I can't get in like castles long
looked 293 then his queen is totally
incarcerated let's try for that
yeah maybe still before you so 90 x if I
chick with the Queen he has a direct
threat down on beside but i can go Quinn
to be 6 this is actually what I had
planned I think for a moment damn i can
also take on c4 actually quincy three
check some big big issue Knight a5
Quincy three check isn't this just
winning I think it is and I'm just
threatening on b3 and Quincy three so
looks at looks like of it I can take
weather might him yeah I guess there's
no point in just move I think resigns
okay yeah he was a it was a provisional
game it was a new account here oh um
what is this five-minute yeah he's new
to five minute he'll pretty decent one
minute rating 2300 something yeah but
this was a very very messy game this g4
is interesting but while I was talking
about my book project I kind of forgot
what I had recommended in the book I
think I think black can basically play
almost you shouldn't take but II five
sorry if I was interesting that was one
thing that I definitely had to recommend
it i'm pretty sure about that and h6
also it's not bad taking is interesting
actually rook g1 and then e 5 d5 bishop
see fire this is a line that i had
analyzed it looks really really weird
but it's quite interesting leads to
leads to very unclear positions okay i
don't remember it exactly what was
interesting
so if I've i think i think i should have
been ok it's a very solid way to play a
five yeah so it gets it gets strange
from here this is a already strange
decision after this i wasn't sure if i
go 95 96 or Bishop f5 this actually
might be an issue I had this idea but he
probably can go g6 or I can take him Jan
but he has to go to see to I think this
is a strange way to play miss placing
the Queen still Quincy to and now just
what i did is i think just good he
cannot really allow night be three so he
took it and here like it's just much
better yeah computers on minus two yeah
i just threaten roop t2 and win and i
really don't see what he's doing again
said this was some flat out losing so
yeah he he played them in an aggressive
but somewhat somewhat non sound fashion
and it really cost him at the end okay
well thanks for watching